hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 2 of
the right and the good one of WT Ross's
major contributions to moral theory he
lays out this this this conception of
prima-facie duties that is duties that
are not always binding in every single
case but which tend to be good
guideposts because they tend to be what
is morally required of us from situation
a situation a situation and one of the
duties that he discusses that's
particularly interesting is this duty of
gratitude and he's not the first
philosopher to discuss this as a matter
of fact Cicero said that gratitude is
the mother of all the virtues Aristotle
discusses gratitude it's one of Hobbes's
laws of nature that you know when
benefits are shown to a person that
person doesn't give that the other
person reason to to regret having
benefited them so gratitude is a theme
that's been made important within
philosophy but Ross actually places it
as a particular kind of duty
so what does he have to say about it
we're gonna look at that and then we'll
look at some of the the problems that
could come up with it he says that if we
want to think of it in terms of duty its
of what we call a special duty so what
would that be different from a general
duty such as justice or beneficence or
non-maleficence those are our duties
that we owe sort of across the board to
everybody regardless of who we are
regardless of what their relationship to
us is for Ross gratitude and I think
he's completely right in this gratitude
stems from the actions of particular
others that have benefited us and our
acceptance of those benefits when we
accept benefits that another person has
provided us it places us under a kind of
obligation to them and and the
obligation can vary from type of benefit
to type of benefit how beneficial it is
but there is this you know I wanted to
use the word general there's this
general conception that in specific
cases I owe something to those who have
benefited me we'll talk about all
different modes of that in a moment
another key thing that Ross says we tend
to associate gratitude with a kind of
feeling or attitude or maybe you know
thoughts about a person Ross says that's
not what really matters it's the actions
that matter so one of the things that we
all do if we want to wrap our heads
around this is we ought to think of the
kinds of actions that a person who is
grateful to another person or perhaps to
an institution we could think of all
sorts of possibilities
what does gratitude actually look like
displayed in behavior or perhaps in
gestures but not just in feelings so
obviously one of the first things that
we could say is the behavior of thinking
you know perhaps writing a thank-you
note something I'm very bad at myself
fortunately the email exists because
when it comes to written thank-you notes
I'm I'm very very bad about sending
those out thinking a person is one sign
of gratitude and in certain cases that
might actually be enough to discharge
the duty so many holds open a door for
you you say thank you that's probably
enough in a case like that walking
through the door without acknowledging
their presence in any way that would be
a jerky move that would be against duty
that would actually be something wrong
in Ross's view you should acknowledge it
you don't just send me a gift basket
because they opened the door for you
that would be a bit excessive so
sometimes the gestures or actions are
tailored to the action you receive a
scholarship
you probably shouldn't just write a
little you know thank you email you
should probably write the scholarship
selection committee or the institution
that's giving it and tell them a little
bit about what you're gonna do with that
scholarship that would be a good thing
to do Ross would say it's not just a
nice thing he doesn't care about nice
and actually neither do I cuz nice
usually isn't the same thing as good
right just anything like that it's the
right thing to do so there's a lot of
things along these lines you know
somebody takes you out to dinner and
they pick up the check
maybe the next time around you say hey
I'm gonna
reciprocate by picking up the check next
time and it could be proportioned
to some degree somebody who's got a lot
of money invites you out to their house
for whatever outing it is you know when
I was a kid for example we would go to
the this house every Christmas for this
big Christmas party that involved
creating a gigantic wreath and you know
stringing lights onto it and pulling it
up to some gigantic house that one of my
day
clients owned and you know is there any
way that my dad could possibly
reciprocate the sort of thing that that
client was inviting him to he actually
invited them all out to his yacht a few
times to well my dad didn't have to cut
and my dad didn't have a big house to to
invite people to so you can't
reciprocate in that way but maybe
there's other ways in which you can you
can reciprocate and maybe the gesture
for somebody who has less resources
doesn't have to be as big as sweeping as
involved as that who has a lot of
resources and a lot of superfluous
wealth and can do things with it so the
duty is to do some sort of action to
reciprocate in some tangible concrete
way not merely to feel grateful to the
person not merely to think good thoughts
about them but to actually do something
that you know it could be conveying that
you could say I feel so grateful as you
write the note but the emphasis is on
actually sending the note not just on
having the feeling as a matter of fact
Rauf says the feeling and here we might
differ with him a bit the feeling is not
something that you actually have a duty
to it's good if you have a feeling but
it's not a matter of right or wrong
so what are the sorts of things that we
need to be grateful for
Ross distinguishes three things that he
says are intrinsic goods virtue
intelligence and pleasure so let's think
about pleasure first somebody does
something that is pleasant for you they
buy you some mp3s and send you an iTunes
gift card saying hey I knew that you
really like this group their new album
just came out I want you to have this
hope it makes you happy that would be an
example of something you would have to
be you should be you want to be grateful
for it would be right for you to
reciprocate in some way at the very
least to send an email thanking them
what are other things that we find
pleasant people invite us out to eat
they buy us rounds of drinks
they send a nice note themselves saying
hey I get a lot of these myself really
like what you're doing with the videos
saying thank you is an appropriate
response to that sort of thing there's
many other types of pleasure somebody
gives you a back massage because they
can tell that you're having a rough day
and it's you know in that case it might
be alleviating pain but it could also be
producing pleasure somebody play's a
song for you
somebody takes you off to the Art
Gallery or to the you know the sports
arena to watch whatever it is that
you're into for me I'd be NFL football
although I do like watching you know
basketball live not on TV we could
imagine all sorts of other things that
we find pleasant going on a vacation
going on a day trip all those sorts of
things could incur duties of gratitude
what about intelligence I sometimes it's
not as frequent this as perhaps it is
with some other professors I sometimes
have students coming up to me at the end
of the semester the very last day and
thanking me for the class that that we
have just engaged in my teaching I'm
doing a lot of homework and a lot of
discussion and a lot of learning on
their part and that's that's them
showing gratitude for me having
benefited them and they're not just
saying hey you know you were really
entertaining the class was super fun
that would be about pleasure instead
there's a recognition that I've helped
them to learn something that they think
is intrinsically valuable usually it's
an ethics class we could say many things
along those sorts of lines should we be
thanking our our teachers our professors
our instructors that seems like
appropriate behavior now if you didn't
actually learn anything from them you're
under no obligation whatsoever Ross
let's say to actually thank them because
they didn't benefit you in terms of
diligence they didn't they didn't
improve your store of knowledge what
about virtue moral virtue Ross says we
owe people gratitude when they benefit
us in those ways so it's not just when
they display virtuous behavior towards
us say being generous or being kind or
being compassionate or being thoughtful
it's when they help us to become better
people now this is an interesting one
because sometimes what it takes in order
for us to improve is experiencing things
that we do find painful could be
punishment it could be somebody telling
us hey I think you're a jerk you really
need to like improve your character
because look at how you behave that's
not easy to hear but those sorts of
things can sometimes be either
cumulatively or or by themself turning
points that people need I remember a
student who came up to me two years
after I had him in class it had been two
years since I had seen him I had on my
very first semester when he was kind of
a young hothead and I was kind of a
young hothead and the very first day in
class he said something about his
opinion and I kind of blew up at him
which wasn't a good thing at you know in
retrospect and I told them nobody cares
anything about your opinion if all you
get is your opinion I don't want to hear
it these other students don't want to
hear it unless you've actually got
something better than just your personal
views something that other people could
find interesting rational entertaining I
don't want to hear and he got you know
he got kind of mad but he but he you
know shut up and didn't say thanks the
rest of the semester and he came up to
me two years later and he said I really
got to thank you that was a turning
point for me nobody had ever said that
to me and I really needed somebody to
say that to me and once I started I was
really mad at you but once I started
thinking about it I realized yeah I
actually I do
to get my act together and stop just you
know saying that things matter because
in my opinion because Who am I you know
I I need to actually be able to say
things that other people could find
reasonable not just because I find them
reasonable but because they find them
reasonable and so that you know I
suppose you could say that was some
intellectual things but that's also
helping them to progress towards towards
better character I know that myself I've
had quite a few of those moments where
people have told me hey you really need
to work on this or wow you you're
totally out of line in this respect and
you know at the time you don't really
feel like taking it sort of like bitter
medicine but it really is helping you to
become a better person morally so that's
something that we ought to be grateful
for those are those are intrinsic goods
Ross would say and then there's all
sorts of instrumental goods you know
somebody saves your life life is is you
know it's a good because it allows you
to enjoy all sorts of other goods you
should be grateful to them even if you
didn't want them to you you know that's
a benefit to you there's all sorts of
other things that we could think of
somebody gives you some money money is
not an intrinsic good money is an
instrumental good still it's a good
somebody benefits you and allows you to
to improve your situation with respect
to some of the other goods so we've
talked about some examples of how people
show gratitude actually display it in
action we've talked about some of the
things people ought to be grateful for
there's several problems that one could
raise which are not insurmountable
problems and Ross does have good
responses to these these sorts of things
but you have to kind of work at them one
would be how do you show gratitude to
people that you are not able to do
anything for in return or you're not
able to do something similar to that in
is there is there a duty just to them or
could that Duty be discharged in other
ways what I have in mind is when we talk
about paying it forward so imagine this
I've got this crazy idea that I'm going
to do random acts of kindness to people
and they'll pay it for it and what we
mean by pay it forward is they're not
going to reciprocate to me they may I
may even like be totally off the scene
they have no idea of who I am by the
time that they experience the benefits
but I put in there something like a note
and I say pay it forward
that means help somebody else out in
turn that's how you're going to display
being grateful not to me but to somebody
else so I help somebody out in in some
way and then they help somebody out and
helping somebody out for them is a good
act on their part but they're doing it
to try to to try to be you know it's
supposed to be an expression of
gratitude towards the strangers behavior
towards them that that somebody did
something good for them
and then the next person does it in the
next person doesn't the next person guys
that would be one way in which this
could be done does that fit into Ross's
conception let's consider some other
somewhat similar cases I would ask my
students how can you be grateful to your
parents for all that they've done to you
and sometimes the students would say
well you know when they get old I'll
take care of them and they may or may
not do that what can you do right now
though I can say thanks but there and
then those students will say but that
doesn't even like seem to come close to
what they've done for me and some of
them will say man I really I can't do
what it is that they've done for me in
return and then they'll say you know I
can make something of myself they've
invested time energy affection interest
your faces in in me in my educational
development in my emotional well-being I
can actually try to be a good person try
to get my screwed-up life on track and
you know keep my improve my grades get a
good job all those sorts of things I can
do to try to say thank you to them for
having given me what I've got so this
this is actually tying in with what Ross
calls the duty of self-improvement which
we're going to look at it another core
concept video self-improvement and and
gratitude could coincide in some ways
just as beneficence in the case of
paying it forward and gratitude could
combine in certain ways now another
problem that you might raise should I be
grateful to people who do good things to
me but then expect me to do something
bad in return to show my gratitude to
them there are many people who do good
things to other people precisely to get
in with them so that they can manipulate
them down the line and get them to do
things that really they shouldn't do
things that go against other duties for
instance taking people out and giving
them a really good time so that you can
sway them to go against the duty of
justice which requires a fair
proportioning of goods I want somebody
to you know give me a bigger share so I
treat them really nice and then if
they're in attempted not to do that I
say hey wait a second are you an ingrate
there's many people who feel that once
they've been benefitted by another
person
look they owe that other person and even
if it transgresses other duties even if
it's wrong because it violates a justice
or non-maleficence or even
self-improvement the duty of
own self or fidelity to to another
person that somehow they're still
obliged to do it and Ross would say well
this is one of those cases where duties
conflict and you really need to think
about which duty in that particular case
is most stringent a duty which is set up
to require you this is where the
manipulative miss comes in to require
you to contravene to go against another
Duty we really want to look at those as
being less stringent so the person who
you're supposed to be grateful to that
that may be a factor in lowering the
amount of gratitude or the way in which
you're supposed to express gratitude to
that person by the way Ross doesn't seem
to think that it's up to the other
person to decide entirely what counts as
gratitude it's it's more up to ourselves
but we shouldn't be cheap or stingy when
it when it comes to that so that's the
prima facie duty of gratitude a lot of
considerations here